[Musique]
nous sommes le 22 février 2030
mon fils louis bercy ni se réveille sur
sa balade de jazz favorite
un morceau de brad mehldau si vous
connaissez nae lover il s'adresse à son
assistant domotique
elvis et lui dit vis super choix pour un
lundi matin tu pouvais pas mieux
souffrir et vises un tu pourrais me
repasser mon costume gris s'il te plaît
celui pour les grandes occasions parce
que j'ai rendez vous à 8 heures avec mon
directeur réunion j'aimerais que ça se
passe au mieux
elvis lui répond alors j'essaie de
prendre la voile un assistant domotique
c'est pas facile une voie peu nasillarde
un peu robotique
désolé louis ça va pas être possible
tu a épuisé son quota énergétique
tu sais celui qui nous est imposée par
la coop 32 plus voyants et ta production
solaire n'a pas été terrible cette
semaine pas brillant du tout ok ok ok ok
je vis ok bon beh bombe et je prendrai
mon costume habituel mais en revanche tu
pourrais me préparer un véhicule
autonome
alors je sais je pourrais prendre le
minibus collectif autonome mais un lundi
matin la circulation à bruxelles c'est
un peu compliqué j'ai vraiment pas envie
d'arriver en retard auxquelles oui je te
prépare ton véhicule autonome tu avais
droit cette semaine à deux véhicules
autonomes et en reste un
le trajet durera plus ou moins un quart
d'heure à 7h45
tiens toi prêt en bas pour le voyage je
prépare aussi
toaster ton café pas trop sucré ton café
glycémie et stress tu sais ça fait pas
bon ménage
merci merci elvis temps se passe
il rentre de fait dans son véhicule
autonome celui qui va l'amener à son
rendez vous et ils épluchent que ça ces
dossiers évidemment pour son rendez vous
avec son directeur d'ici un quart
d'heure
je dois vous dire louis travail dans un
office de notaire c'est pas évidemment
pourquoi il a cet entretien il épluche
ces dossiers et pendant qu'ils épluchent
et dossier il peut pas s'empêcher de
regarder par les vitres du véhicule et
de s'émerveiller comme à chaque fois
dans ces villes de la disparition
complète de tout panneau de
signalisation de tous feux rouges
devenues évidemment totalement inutile
alors de ces véhicules super intelligent
et qui en plus se parlent se coordonne
sa lé panneau de signalisation le code
de la route c'est un truc pour les
humains c'est un truc pour pallier les
défaillances humaines au volant à
l'heure des véhicules intelligents et
des véhicules en relation plus besoin de
code de la route que de la route c'est
une chose ringarde code de la route
c'est une chose humaine et louis de
s'interroger sur la possible disparition
de toute forme de législation à
destination des humains dès lors que ses
algorithmes sont là pour mieux faire il
continue de fait à éplucher tous ces
dossiers toujours en guise de
préparation de cette réunion
et il entend à la radio des nouvelles il
entend que les drones américains ont
fait 3000 victimes à 50 km de pékin
3000 big dog savez les derniers robot de
la génération lethal weapon cette
entreprise chinoise qui fabrique ces
robots il arrive chez son patron
son patron l'accueil je dirais pas
forcément avec une mine des bons jours
tôt une mine renfrognée louis
asseyez-vous les nouvelles que j'ai à
vous donner ne sont pas très bonnes
vous savez cette fameuse blocs shane
blocs chaînes dont on parle dont on
parlait depuis des années des années des
années des années
louis malheureusement sept blocs china
huguen de nos de nos travaux la société
va devoir se débarrasser du est le
travail de notaire un peu comme le
travail de banquier
ça consiste à quoi ça consiste à écrire
et réaliser penser des contrats les
authentifier
et puis bien sûr s'assurer de leur bonne
et due exécution les notaires agissent
comme tiers de confiance et vous savez
louis 7 blog
une nuit tout ça au rancart on a tout
algorithmes ise temps la réalisation des
contrats que leur confiance
les algorithmes aujourd'hui et internet
agissent comme tiers de confiance
pendant très longtemps louis la
confiance a été chose humaine c'est fini
aujourd'hui nous accordons plus de
confiance aux algorithmes qu'aux hommes
imagine évidemment à la tête de luiz est
pas une très bonne nouvelle donc louis
retourne dans son bureau il emballe ses
affaires un bureau qui va devoir déserté
donc il emballe ses paquets il fait ses
cartons
il est en rage
il est en colère il se rue sur son
smartphone et il envoie un message à sa
dulcinée syrie moi je suis licencié
envies de meurtre quatre points
d'exclamation il peut reprendre
maintenant le minibus collectif autonome
a plus besoin de prendre la voiture y a
plus vraiment d'urgence il est il arrive
chez lui et au moment où il s'apprête à
franchir le pas de la porte se voit
soudain saisi au corps par deux malabars
de de la génération précogs qui varient
par les épaules
louis versini vous êtes en état
d'arrestation
c'est là évidemment qui se rappelle son
message envies de meurtre évidemment
police prédictive voilà c'est un
scénario pour 2030
est ce que vous avez envie de vivre une
journée comme ça c'est évidemment une
question tu finirais par vous poser
mais d'où vient ce cénacle d'où vient
cette réflexion est bien parce que en
fait on peut partir de deux constats
un constat noir un constat pessimiste et
puis un constat un peu plus joyeux
constat optimiste alors le constat noir
sans doute le partagerai vous c'est
qu'on a quand même l'impression que les
temps sont difficiles que le monde va
pas très bien que depuis 20-30 ans la
terre perd un peu la boule et que vous
ne va pas très bien le monde des rails
et qu'on a l'impression qu'il ya plus
personne aujourd'hui qui est capable de
le remettre sur les rails en tout cas
plus aucun système de gouvernance
humains comme nous les connaissons
semble capable hammam de remettre ce
monde sur les rails
et si ce monde des rails c'est parce
qu'il vient trop complexe
il est gagné par une complexification
croissante savez nous physicien
informaticiens ce qu'on appelle la
complexité c'est quand on met ensemble
des réalités qui détache et localement
serait viable serait encore contrôlable
mais quand vous les mettez tout ensemble
vous créiez des tout don de fait la
gestion nous échappe des to qui
deviennent pratiquement hors contrôle
imprévisible par exemple la jonction
la collection des intérêts individuels
ne fait pas le bien comme ne fait pas
l'intérêt public à cause des passagers
clandestins à cause des gens qui
trichent et qui détourne la société à
leur profit l'enchaînement d'émissions à
court terme ne réalise pas les objectifs
à long terme
là encore la jonction du micro réalités
locales ne satisfait pas le global et
avec cette complexification évidemment
nous sommes soumis à l'ensemble de
menaces je vais rien vous apprendre on
n'arrête pas d'en parler de ces menaces
menace environnementale la plus
incroyable tragédie des communs que
notre que notre époque est en train de
vivre le réchauffement climatique et
tout évidemment tous les désastres
environnementaux qui s'ensuivent menaçe
économique succession sans fin des
crises économiques
là aussi on crée des systèmes d'une
grande fragilité systémique par exemple
les banques un des systèmes bancaires
les banques se prêtent mutuellement
il suffit que l'une d'elles fasse
faillite et elle entraîne dans sa chute
toutes celles qui lui sont connectés les
inégalités explosive on a beau écrire
des essais les uns après les autres se
plaignant c'est me vendre ces inégalités
mais rien n'y fait on n'arrive pas à
jean on n'arrive pas à juguler ces
inégalités menace sociétal on en a parlé
déjà tout à l'heure explosion des
communautarismes flambée du terrorisme
c'est pas de fait un tableau très très
réjouissant et maintenant un constat
plus positif je suis informaticien et en
tant qu'informaticien et je suis
informaticien je travaille en
intelligence artificielle depuis presque
trente ans en tant qu'un terrain voilà
informaticien travaillant dans ces
domaines
on ne peut pas manquer de s'émerveiller
devant tout ce que l'ordinateur
aujourd'hui soit capable de faire
meilleur joueur d'échecs meilleur jour 2
go vous entendez à chaque fois ses
exploits sont relayées dans la presse
meilleur joueur de poker meilleurs
joueurs un jeu
américains mais dont notre qui valent en
français serait question pour un
champion meilleurs conducteurs merci et
mêlera j'en passe et des meilleurs et
donc voilà une informatique
extraordinairement intelligente supra
cognitif super intelligente l'appellent
certains l'informatique non seulement
intelligente mais qui se niche partout
qui envahit tous les recoins de nos
existences
tous les objets peuvent être dotés de
cette intelligence des objets qui non
seulement sont intelligents sont partout
sont ubiquitaire mais se connectent
entre eux peuvent coordonner leurs
actions peuvent synchroniser leurs
actions pour deux fait participer de
cette harmonisation sociale
quand vous mettez ces deux constats et
quand vous les rejoignent et l'envié
forte et c'est de fait ce que je vais
plaider jusqu'à un certain point
l'envié forte de penser que ces
solutions sont les solutions les
solutions informatiques les solutions
algorithmique serait celle qui
permettrait évidemment de répondre à ces
menaces
la technologie est là pour nous aider à
y faire face
bien sûr ça certaines conditions il
faudrait accepter ces textes et cette
acceptation qui va faire débat il
faudrait accepter jusqu'à un certain
point de confier nos existences à des
algorithmes faudrait accepter de se
soumettre là encore jusqu'à un certain
point un big brother appelé le titre de
mon intervention à big brother mais un
big brother évidemment numérique et un
big brother bienveillant un big brother
dont la seule motivation serait
d'aligner les intérêts individuels avec
celui de la collectivité
le prix à payer c'est que ses
algorithmes évidemment verrouillerait
cadenas serait fermerait certains de nos
libertés
mais évidemment pour un enjeu
transcendant un enjeu plus supérieur qui
est l'enjeu sociétal enjeu sur lequel
bien sûr nous devrons nous mettre
d'accord n'est pas question que ces
algorithmes invente même des fonctions
de coût social c'est à nous d'en décider
d'en délibérer
mais est-ce que ses algorithmes ont
efficace c'est que leur pouvoir
d'exécution et leur pouvoir de
coercition peut être supérieur à celui
de toute autre forme de législation et
sans doute vu l'urgence l'urgence dont
je vous parlais nous n'aurions d'autres
recours
pour l'exécution de ces contraintes et
de ces restrictions de liberté de se
confier à ses algorithmes nous
confierions alors nos existences à une
forme de dictature dictature numérique
et j'ai envie de dire une dictature soft
saufs selon les deux acceptation du
terme soft parce que douce et
bienveillante et soft parce que software
nous filerons alors nos existences et
nous nous deviendrons comme ça sera ma
dernière photo nous devrions accepter de
prendre un peu la place de truman comme
vous savez dans le fameux truman show
truman
comme vous le voyez sur la photo vie en
totale félicité affichant un espèce de
bonheur béat dans un monde pourtant qui
est totalement calibre est totalement
formaté dont il est impossible de
s'échapper les murs algorithmique voyait
l'analogie les murs algorithmique sont
là mais procure à ses habitants une
espèce de bonheur infini
la question que je pose évidemment c'est
accepterons-nous de confier nos
existences à ce big brother numérique
soft bienveillant et je pense vraiment
qu'il est urgent d'y répondre
parce que si nous lui répondons pas et
si nous ne trouvons pas aller voir de la
réponse il est fort possible que
d'autres big brother mais cette fois ci
beaucoup moins soft style par exemple et
gaf a les gaffes à sont aux avant postes
de cette dictature numérique ils ont
tout en main pour réaliser cette
dictature numérique encore ils sont
software mais y aurait d'autres big
brother beaucoup moins bienveillant des
simples dictature qui pourrait trouver
une réponse
donc je réitère et je terminerai par ça
répondant à cette question les
algorithmes ou d'autres big brother
beaucoup moins bienveillants merci
hop